le président des Radicaux de Gauche
Jean-Michel Baillet par ailleurs
sénateur du Tarn-et-Garonne et l'invité
de preuve par 3 bonsoir bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes un allié
loyal de la majorité présidentielle
fidèle mais quand même souvent jaloux
d'autres composantes notamment les
écologistes nous en parlerons au cours
de cette émission avec moi ce soir quel
est le Prigent de l'Agence France Presse
notre partenaire avec Dailymotion et
puis bien sûr Perrine Tarnaud de Public
Sénat d'abord Jean-Michel Baillet est-ce
que vous comprenez le record d'un
popularité qui frappe François Hollande
aujourd'hui sans précédent sous la
Cinquième République je trouve tout cela
est excessif et pour tout vous dire
injuste certes je comprends que l'état
dans lequel nous avons trouvé la France
la nécessité de réforme et finalement
l'application de ce que François
Hollande avait promis aux Français le
redressement il faut redresser la France
mais pour cela dans un cadre global très
compliqué douloureux le Red bien sûr
c'est douloureux parce qu'il faut faire
des efforts considérables que c'est la
gauche qui d'ailleurs comme à chaque
fois notre histoire à faire entre
guillemets le sale boulot parce qu'il
faut faire des efforts et donc demander
des efforts alors bien naturellement les
Français inquiétude légitimes et
compréhensible pour leur emploi pour
leur pouvoir d'achat et ça le rend pas
populaire mais rendons au moins hommage
à Hollande pour sa détermination et son
courage il ne gouverne pas et les
sondages c'est loin de l'obus dire il
gouverne il gouverne avec le fil
directeur qui a été le sien dès son
élection je veux redresser la France je
vais lui rendre sa compétitivité est-ce
qu'il peut encore gouverner malgré ses
sondages bien sûr qu'il peut gouverner
la
politique ne se fait pas dans la rue la
politique elle se fait au gouvernement
et au Parlement et bien entendu qu'il
peut réformer et nous allons en parler
aujourd'hui encore une grande réforme
vient d'être annoncée ce matin par le
Premier ministre continuer à faire des
réforme la France on a besoin vous nous
parlez Jean-Michel balade de la douleur
du redressement et de la situation
économique et il y a pas que ça qui
cloche vous le savez bien qu'il rentre
des choses difficiles il y a aussi
quelque chose qui ne marche pas dans
l'exécutif
qu'est-ce qui ne marche pas vous voulez
me verdir que le premier ministre est le
Président
je vous renvoie au passé je crois et nul
ne contestera même pas vous que François
Hollande a plus de conscience pour son
premier ministre que l'on avait Nicolas
Sarkozy et je trouve qu'ils font du bon
travail ensemble et qu'il et qu'il le
font la main dans la main ceci étant dit
le quinquennat a fondamentalement changé
les choses à partir du moment où le
préalabilité du prochain cas tout
naturellement c'est vers lui que tout
converge et c'est la plus protection en
tout cas beaucoup moins le point commun
et ils ont une vieille complicité ils
travaillent déjà dans sa maison
nationale ensemble mais c'est le
quinquennat qui a modifié les choses
donc alors au bout de la logique comme
le radicaux le demande depuis longtemps
moi j'avais déposé une proposition de
loi ici même au Sénat et une autre les
radicaux à l'Assemblée pour que nous
mettions le droit à un il est fait et
que nous changeons de République il faut
la Sixième République reconnaissons que
nous serons en régime présidentiel donc
donnons les pouvoirs présidents
supprimant le poste de Premier ministre
et établissons un véritable contrepoids
parce qu'elle n'a pas trop quand même
quand une période de cohabitation ce qui
est quand même encore un véritable
compte au pouvoir dans une évocation
c'est le Parlement très bien alors vous
dites que François Hollande encore toute
l'autorité pour réformer aujourd'hui
Jean-François Copé le patron le
président de l'UMP estime que l'autorité
présidentielle s'est effondrée avec
François Hollande que répondez-vous moi
j'ai envie de répondre Jean-François
Copé qui ferait mieux de regarder sa
propre autorité sur ses propres troupes
et son propre parti quand on voit les
conditions dans lesquelles il a été élu
c'est un homme de caricatures d'excès
Jean-François Copé que nous ayons des
difficultés c'est vrai que certains
contestent l'autorité par la République
c'est la règle du jeu en toute
démocratie et quand est-ce que à
commander il a tort on passe avec
François Hollande de critiques de
décision qui serait trop forte je pense
par exemple lorsqu'il a tranché dans ce
que l'on appelait à faire léonarda au
contraire disons que il ne décide pas
alors il faudrait savoir quand on dit la
vérité moi je trouve qu'un sol Hollande
est équilibré d'ailleurs c'est assez sa
nature mais quand il faut décider il
décide quand il faut ranger il faut que
tout va bien changer il est aujourd'hui
un voyage en Israël
regardez quand même les positions qu'il
a prises courageuse vis-à-vis de l'Iran
c'est pas rien là on sort un peu de
l'Hexagone on est sur la scène
internationale il a eu le courage de
dire des choses féliciter par beaucoup
de monde la voie de la France se fait
entendre en Europe dans le monde c'est
un homme courageux qu'il ne faille rien
changer c'est bien sûr et excessive mais
dans la manière de gouverner bien sûr
qu'est-ce qu'il faut changer il faut
mettre peut-être un peu plus bile dans
les rouages puisque quand même
impopularité on peut pas ne pas la
prendre en compte et il faut réfléchir
aux raisons de tout cela mais voilà ne
soyons pas dans le toutou rien d'accord
je trouve que au bout de 18 mois 18 mois
simplement il reste trois et demi quand
même ne l'oublions pas et c'est à ce
moment-là qu'il doit faire le bilan et
juger c'est pas au bout de 18 mois je
trouve qu'en 18 mois beaucoup de
réformes ont été portées certaines sont
déjà continue
cela même ligne politique parce qu'il y
en a pas d'autres pour redresser la
France bien expliqué bien naturellement
il faut peut-être mieux communiquer et
un peu plus d'harmonie au sein de la
majorité pas de pas d'électrochoc
politique un remaniement par exemple
mais un roman certains réclament
d'urgence
toujours tout et parfois son contraire
moi je dis que là encore il faut être
cohérent et déterminé je crois
il se fait généralement ce qu'on appelle
le médiateur donc à peu près à la moitié
du quinquennat ça tombe bien nous serons
à peu près la moitié quinquennat après
les élections européennes on attend ce
moment-là bien sûr on va pas remanier ni
en ce moment où nous sommes en période
de loi de finance ni à quelques mois des
municipales ni à quelques semaines des
Européens après nous verrons nous serons
pratiquement à mi-manda il appartient de
l'état de dire ce qu'il veut faire
envoyer ce nouvel élan va mis parcours
mi-mandat écoutez nous verrons moi je ne
vais pas me lancer dans la politique
fiction effectivement il serait
souhaitable de trouver un second souffle
mais c'est aussi pour cela que très
souvent il n'y a eu pratiquement qu'une
exception c'est François Fillon un chat
on change le gouvernement à l'ami
parcours alors je ne sais pas si c'est
ce que décidera François Hollande mais
je pense que quel que soit ses décisions
il faudra partir sur nos souvenirs
jamais caché non plus François Hollande
on peut le critiquer beaucoup ne se gêne
pas mais on ne peut pas dire qu'ils n'en
sait pas ce qu'il va il avait dit que le
début ce serait difficile qu'il faudrait
faire beaucoup d'efforts
Premier ministre en cours de mandat vous
vous voyez qui par exemple non non non
pierre rafferin qui nous a dit que par
exemple Martine Aubry aurait le profil
idéal pour s'installer la matière parce
que justement elle est complémentaire de
François Hollande sur tous les plans
politique et peut-être du caractère
aussi à partir c'est le chef de l'État
le chef de l'État et
s'il est des hommes auxquels je
n'appartiennent pas se sont bien
responsables de l'opposition la France
est un pays délicieux ou l'opposition
fait le gouvernement et où dans la
majorité et bien on bosse et on essaie
de se taire ça marche mieux ainsi
Emmanuel une question Emmanuel Valls
serait bien remarquable ministre de
l'Intérieur et l'homme politique de
grand talent voilà après son chef de
l'État a choisi d'accord d'accord
aujourd'hui en tous les cas vous l'avez
rappelé Jean-Michel bailette Jean-Marc
Ayrault tente qui ressemble quand même
un coup de poker l'annonce d'une vaste
réforme de la fiscalité c'est un coup de
poker que quand le chef du gouvernement
il y a bien longtemps on en parle de la
fiscalité et aujourd'hui les Français
disent que les impôts leur sont
insupportables ils le disent d'ailleurs
depuis que les radicaux ont créé
l'important c'est pas nouveau caillot
qui a créé l'impôt sur le revenu qui est
quelque chose de très juste parce qu'on
contribue en fonction de ses capacités
respectives
leur ras-le-bol fiscal que les gens
expriment en ce moment est très juste
parce qu'il est progressif donc il y a
un vrai débat qui avait été ouvert
pendant la campagne électorale et que
les radicaux avaient porté bien avant la
campagne électorale je rappelle que
c'est nous qui les premiers nous les
radicaux avant de demander une fusion de
l'impôt sur le revenu de la CSG et d'une
grande partie aussi
vous le partagiez avec François Hollande
espèce mais aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est
un coup de poker du Premier ministre
tout le monde nique que la fiscalité est
injuste tout le monde dit qu'il faut
revoir les choses
sont trop lourds or la réforme ne me dit
pas baisser les impôts
c'est vrai qu'il a fallu demander
considérable aux Français mais c'est
vrai aussi que ça commence à porter ses
fruits au bien timidement mais on rentre
plus tôt on rentre plutôt dans 0,405 de
croissance alors que nous étions en
négatif on voit que sur le front de
l'emploi
d'achat des français mais aussi sur la
croissance sur la compétitivité des
entreprises par exemple dès aujourd'hui
le medefreagi ils veulent pas participer
à ce jeu de bonne tour en disant que les
impôts pèsent sur la compétitivité
le Medef comme référent le Medef passe
son temps
on va pas partir
de charge quand je vois les sociétés qui
sont les grandes sociétés du Medef a
commencé par celle d’ailleurs du
président du Bénin je n'ai pas
l'impression quand même qu'il soit en
grande difficulté et en plus je n'ai pas
l'impression que ce soit eux qui payent
le plus d'impôts parce que généralement
ils sont délocalisés ils sont à peu près
à 8% alors que les PME PMI sont en train
de bourse donc je crois qu'ils sont mal
placés pour ce verre par contre qu'un
certain nombre citoyen qui était
pratiquement exonérés d'impôts ou qui
ont payé très peu et qui ont vu leurs
charges fiscale augmenter soit perturbé
et mécontents je le comprends et
d'ailleurs j'avais dit déjà il y a un an
après la République ce problème a exposé
qu'il fallait faire une pause fiscale je
suis très heureux que c'est aujourd'hui
une réalité vous soutenez l'annonce donc
c'est cette mise à plat de la fiscalité
et ça prendra des années vous êtes
d'accord ça prenons plusieurs années
plusieurs années socialiste Christian
hacker le rapporteur du du budget à
l'Assemblée plusieurs années ne sont pas
les mêmes que celles du gouvernement
précédent avant le poêle République
décider souvenez-vous dans cette
présentation de la TVA un beau jour il
va à la télévision outils de
communication remarquable et dit je
supprime la publicité à la télévision et
l'autre fois c'était je supprime la
fiscalité locale c'est pas non mais
d'accord
et toutes celles et tous ceux qui sont
concernés c'est cela la méthode de ce
gouvernement
c'est le dialogue et après la
concertation entre concertation avec les
partenaires sociaux dont le Medef il
sera là
plusieurs années un peu particulier
ça veut dire que l'écotaxe est renvoyé
au calendrier moi je regrette beaucoup
d'abord l'appellation des contacts
j'aurais préféré et co contribution mais
je regrette que l'on ait reculer
là-dessus je dis fragile je comprends
que le premier ministre est pris cette
décision car il avait une Bretagne un
véritable révolution ça aussi d'ailleurs
c'est les comportements qui laissent qui
donne à réfléchir mais c'est ainsi mais
si les quelque chose juste et que la
plupart des pays européens mis en place
c'est bien c'était qu'au taxe les
camions qu'est-ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
d'autoriser 48 tonnes paresseux qui
polluent et qui abîment il est normal
qu'il paye une taxe pour réparer les
routes et aussi mieux structurer
le rail le rail et la mesure à sa
logique effectivement quand est-ce que
vous voulez la voir elle est suspendue
moi en ce qui me concerne moi le plus
rapidement possible légèrement je suis
bien conscient que le prix avait
impossible ça sera pas tout de suite
étant donné la situation gouverner c'est
aussi l'art du possible cher Monsieur
voilà
une partie de la France qui est en
révolution avec d'ailleurs des mixage un
peu originaux entre les uns et les
autres pour protester et bien il faut en
tenir compte autrement on sonne dans la
violence et c'est un des preuves une
épreuve responsabilité d'un gouvernement
du chef de l'État d'assurer la paix
civile et la tranquillité et la sécurité
des citoyens pas avant 2015 donc
finalement
le ministre d'écologie a eu raison
même si il a été démenti par le Premier
ministre encore un nouveau quoi non
c'est pas un quoi le ministre
à 12 mois c'est quand même pas très loin
parce que c'est en 13 mois exactement
fiscale pour vous est-ce qu'il faut
maintenir la TVA augmenter au premier
janvier il ne faut plus céder sur le
revendication catégorielle sauf quand
elles sont justes et cela ne le sont pas
il faut quand même bien voir que la TVA
elle est à 1960 pour tout le monde soyez
dans bassin là non plus personne ne
rappelle que le gouvernement Sarkozy
avait décidé la portée avec 21,2 de
l'augmenter d'un virgule si oui mais
parce que
TVA quand j'entends aussi les
corporations parce que c'est gagnant
avec François Le Corporation en
l'occurrence oui récupérer après tout
cela souvenez-vous que le gouvernement
précédent avait décidé
21,2 nous sommes dans les taux réduits
il était le 5 ennemi là encore nos
précédeurs l'emporté à 7 de 5,5 nous
voulons pour financer le sise qui est
nécessaire compétitivité des entreprises
et qui va quand même permettre de
dégager 20 milliards pour les
entreprises et en particulier pour les
PME PMI artisanat etc le porter à 10 au
1er janvier c'est encore un taux réduit
c'est pratiquement c'est la moitié du
taux ordinaire
je trouve qu'on est dans une espèce de
de corporate qui nécessite que la France
affectionne c'est vrai et surtout quand
on est certain pas se leur temps mettre
lui sur le feu à exciter sur
les agriculteurs les artisans ils disent
qu'ils sont tous au bord du bout de
bilan en même temps prenons les
agriculteurs
prenons l'exemple de l'agriculteur ce
qui vit tu perds c'est ceux de
l'Île-de-France de la bosse de l'abri
parce que effectivement ils auront un
peu moins de prime pas parce que il
prenait le pactole au détriment de tous
les autres et il est vrai que cette
fois-ci on a décidé d'être plus juste et
de mieux répartir y compris vers les
petits endroits laissez-moi parce que
c'est blocus de Paris c'est le blocus de
Paris il est fait par quelques gros
agriculteurs d'Île-de-France qui ont des
exploitation de de betterave et autres
dans la brosse à l'abri qui généralement
avec tous Paris d'ailleurs voilà bien
particulier mais les agriculteurs de
chez moi
et bien justement ils sont plutôt
satisfaits à la manière dont la pâte a
été négocié moins 7 et demi pour le
budget pas grand général moins d'un demi
pour l'objet pack France très bien merci
Monsieur belle est allez on va continuer
maintenant avec quel prix genre de
l'Agence France Presse elle va nous
rejoindre juste avant on va voir avec
Sophie normand si François Hollande
n'est pas victime de la difficulté
parfois souvent dit-on à trancher entre
les différentes composantes de sa
majorité entre par exemple voilà gauche
du PS et les écologistes
il n'avait que 28% au premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle François
Hollande a été élu au second tour avec
le Front de gauche et les écologistes
une majorité disparate qui 18 mois après
la victoire de la gauche se fissure une
situation qui viendrait d'une faiblesse
initiale nous n'avons pas rassemblé dès
notre élection l'ensemble des forces de
gauche écologistes autour d'un pacte
gouvernemental et législatif cohérent le
Parti radical de gauche se dit délaissé
au profit des écologistes qui eux
reprochent au président de gouverner
seul entre la majorité et François
Hollande le lien semble distendu il y a
une gouvernance très étroite en effet
très étroite au niveau de quelques-uns
gouvernements très étroites autour du
cabinet du président est très étroite
autour du président là maintenant il
faut écouter la base de celles et ceux
qui ont voté pour lui mais parce que
évidemment il parle aussi à l'ensemble
de la France mais peut pas parler avec
la France centriste il faut qu'il parle
à la France socialiste il faut qu'il
parle à la France écologiste et même à
la gauche la France communiste loin
d'apaiser les tensions les communistes
justement protagon reste de la majorité
parlementaire mettent un peu plus
d'huile sur le feu non seulement nous ne
sommes pas entendus mais Pierre que cela
nous sommes méprisés autant l'année
dernière ça c'est un petit peu mieux
passé dans les relations entre par
exemple mon groupe et le gouvernement
cette année strictement rien par exemple
à l'eau du débat sur le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale ou
que ce soit celui sur le PLF 2014 nous
n'avons pas de rencontre avec les
ministres concernés les parlementaires
de gauche attendent aujourd'hui de
François Hollande qu'il rencontre les
leaders des différents courants et
celles avec et entre eux un nouveau
pacte combiné à un changement de cap et
un retour au fondamentaux de la gauche
voilà avec nous donc Katel président
bonsoir Katell notre concert de l'Agence
France vos questions à Monsieur Baillet
alors vous avez deux ministres au sein
du gouvernement les écologistes aussi et
pourtant vous dites qu'il y a un
traitement de faveur de la part de
l'exécutif envers les écologistes est-ce
que vous estimez être moins bien traité
que les écologistes
les écologistes
ont de la part des points de la
République les yeux de Chimène
alors tout cela s'est affectif c'est pas
grave mais il faut que les radicaux
soient mieux entendus et je reconnais
que depuis quelques semaines il irait
progrès j'avais demandé qu'il y ait des
réunions globales de toutes les
formations la majorité avec les prix en
gros ça a été le cas tant que j'ai pas
la République chez le Premier ministre
nous avons maintenant des comptes
réguliers avec le Premier ministre plus
régulier avec le prix en république les
choses vont mieux mais objectivement
dans les 18 mois de gouvernement on voit
que les écologistes ont été très écoutés
dans ce qu'il souhaitait voir prise en
compte dans la politique gouvernementale
le mois de lombusir c'est que les
radicaux ne l'ont pas été beaucoup je
prends l'exemple des du
démonstitutionnel ou n'en avons été
entendu c'est rien et nous le regrettons
d'ailleurs si on nous avait écouté
aujourd'hui le Congrès des maires se
passerait un peu mieux parce que
certaines réformes qui ont été portées
des mers
j'ai mené la campagne primaire en disant
clairement les choses et l'opposition
c'est vrai que le Parti socialiste parce
que le Parti socialiste avait une autre
position qui a repris frère François
Hollande bon mais c'est pas parce que
nous sommes aujourd'hui la majorité que
nous sommes d'accord surtout et surtout
comment et puis les particulièrement
parce que je n'ai pris personne en prête
tout le monde le savait d'ailleurs on
s'en est expliqué le Premier
ministre ils savent très bien quels sont
les positionnements radicaux mais
reprenez un homme guérison le découpage
des cantons ce fameux binôme ça fait
hurler tout le monde dans la dans la
ruralité ça brise la proximité là encore
si on avait écouté les radicaux on
aurait fait autrement donne nous n'avons
pas été jusqu'à maintenant suffisamment
entendu les grandes réformes
institutionnelles sont derrière nous
vous écoutez que nous saurons plus mieux
endormie pas du tout c'est pas du
conservatisme c'est la réalité la
connaissance de terrain parce que les
radicaux sont des élus de terrain
contrairement à des écologistes qui sont
plutôt des des rats des villes et liées
à Paris et dans la dans
les écologistes ont quand même des élus
dans les régions aussi dans le
département
ils n'ont pas de merde ils n'ont des
élus qu'à la proportionnelle selon le
bon vouloir du Parti socialiste alors
que nous nous avons des élus parfois
dans le parti socialistes parfois en
primaire avec le Parti socialiste et
nous savons ce qu'est la réalité des
choses et aujourd'hui je répète que le
Congrès des mères se passerait un peu
plus tranquillement si nos envies ont
été mises ceci étant dit désormais les
choses vont mieux parce que nous avons
mis en place des instances de
concertation et aussi parce qu'on a
peut-être compris qu'il fallait entendre
celles et ceux qui prônent la raison par
rapport à ceux qui prennent la passion
permanente la politique ça ne peut pas
être que le le feu et la fureur tout le
temps
je vois certaines déclarations
vous ne ferez pas faire de la même ça
non non
vous voulez qu'on non et vous vous
réagissez par exemple
j'aurais sans placer par exemple sur la
déclaration appelant les lycéens
manifester c'est déplacé pour un
responsable politique bien naturellement
aussi par certains directions
est-ce que vous suivez un petit peu de
loin le Congrès qui se prépare chez les
verts ou justement une autre voie se
fait entendre et notamment qui critique
beaucoup la participation au
gouvernement
de gauche je ne m'occupe pas des congrès
des autres mais je vois bien
effectivement que justement sur ce
congrès aussi moi je ne suis pas prêt à
la République du moins pour l'instant et
donc je n'ai pas occupé le jour ce sera
le cas je vous promets je m'occuperai du
Congrès des Verts mais pas comme ça
quand même et justement sur ce manque
d'écoute de l'exécutif vous concernant
ce que vous êtes vous n'avez pas
l'impression de payer une longue
tradition justement de partenariat avec
le PS c'est que on finit par plus trop
moi je vous ai parlé franchement le
début est un peu difficile on ne tient
pas assez entendu désormais nous avons
mis
un certain nombre de méthodes nous
rencontrons plus souvent la concertation
a lieu et les choses ont beaucoup mieux
et puis bon c'est quand même que les
radicaux sont des alliés fidèles et
loyaux qui sont toujours attentifs c'est
pas le cas de tout le monde y compris
pour les votes du budget voilà parce que
c'est le pacte fondateur du majorité de
la Fontaine
alors là vous avez peut-être été entendu
c'est notamment quand vous avez éreinté
Harlem Désir justement sur la faire
léonarda vous en parliez tout à l'heure
vous avez estimé sa critique pas
acceptable vous l'avez parlé de Tintin
avec le général tapioca oui parce que je
me suis référé à une bande dessinée que
j'aime bien c'est une réaction de
moments et je ne retirais à ce que j'ai
dit dans la mesure où c'était la
première fois qu'un responsable le
premier d'entre eux du parti du prêt à
la République
contester une décision importante et pas
la République bon depuis les choses se
sont normalisées nous venons de passer
un accord à le Parti socialiste y
compris pour les élections européennes
et je dois dire quand même désir a
parfaitement du sengagement et sa parole
vous voyez que je sais aussi reconnaître
les choses et et et vendez la qualité
d'un politique quand je le pense mais
moi je parle en langage de vérité vous
parliez d'accord cet accord c'est donc
qui vous donne une tête de liste sur la
dans le Grand Sud-Ouest il y a quoi dans
cet accord nous avons passé un accord
électoral pour les élections européennes
avec une tête de Lise à la Grand
Sud-Ouest quelques autres postes en
place non éligibles ou charnières et
nous ont passé un accord aussi sur les
sénatoriales prochaine afin de préserver
notre groupe car nous sommes très très
attachés désormais avoir un groupe
parlementaire à l'Assemblée au Sénat et
les choses se passeront bien je pense
aux élections sénatoriales également
puisque nous aurions être en conquête de
liste qui sera une femme
on en sait un peu plus ou pas
le temps de me retourner moi je ne suis
pas un congrès mais les radicaux a aussi
leur statut aussi leur méthode leur
tradition et parfois aussi un peu leurs
affrontements parce que vous avez deux
femmes ministres personnellement ce ne
sera pas l'une d'elles qui sera
peut-être de liste européennes je n'en
ai pas encore parlé avec elle je sais
que ça s'est dit mais je ne pense pas
que ce soit judicieux parce que si une
des deux femmes ministres sont tous les
deux de très belles qualités et les
magnifiques combattantes elle serait
capable de mener cette campagne l'une et
l'autre mais à partir du moment elles
sont élus celle qui le gouvernement lui
et c'est la prise l'autre député dans
leur vie non plutôt parlement national
ce qui fait que nous perdons notre siège
de député européenne ça serait pas une
très bonne affaire sur le plan politique
pour les radis que pensez-vous du fait
que Vincent payant le ministre de
l'éducation nationale décide de de se
lancer à nouveau à la conquête d'un
siège européen est un homme qui a
beaucoup œuvré au sein d'Union
Européenne il aime le Parlement européen
c'est une convaincu comme moi d'ailleurs
et il a envie le monde dit de retourner
siéger auparavant se mettre à l'abri non
c'est pas de se mettre à l'abri il
restera certainement au gouvernement
mais le moment
son siège de député européen et c'est
quelque chose d'important pour lui parce
que c'est un de des politiques français
de haut niveau qui se sont toujours
engagés sur le plan européen uniquement
sur le plan européen
tout va pour le mieux donc dans le
meilleur des mondes avec le PS vous êtes
récompenses dans les couples vous le
savez tout ne va jamais pour le mieux le
meilleur des mondes il faut savoir
faire la part des choses et je trouve
que désormais nous travaillons bien la
main à la main puis peut-être aussi que
les difficultés que sont les nôtres nous
rapproche parce que nous sommes quand
même des des militants politiques et des
responsables politiques qui avons le
sens de de la raison le sens de l'État
et le sang responsabilités quand on
travaille des mondes difficiles des
moments difficiles ce n'est pas le
moment de faire tanguer un peu d'accord
on l'entend bien depuis le début de
cette émission on n'a pas réjouit d'une
prise de guerre entre guillemets c'est
Philippe Esnol oui Philippe donne nous
en rejoint moi je suis toujours ravi
quand des élus de bon niveau nous
rejoint mais il y a quelques socialistes
nous rejoignent en ce moment il y en a
un autre maire de la région parisienne
que
c'est parfois par la politique
ils ont peut-être découvert à quelqu'un
les radicaux et surtout les valeurs
républicaines que nous portons et qui
sont totalement d'actualité parce que
quand même s'il est un courant politique
et d'actualité c'est bien le radicalisme
dans la défense de la République dans la
lutte contre le racisme dans la défense
de la laïcité c'est quand même ça les
valeurs radicales
lutte contre le racisme vous avez
participé justement aux meeting
republicains et organisé par le PS nous
l'avons décidé ensemble nous avons
décidé ensemble la semaine dernière
parce que nous avons considéré à
l'indésir moi-même et quelques autres
responsables politiques y compris des
ministres y compris
socialiste au Sénat que nous nous
pouvions pas rester sans réagir devant
non seulement une telle montée du
racisme et de l'intolérance avec toutes
les conséquences que tout cela peut
avoir sur le comportement de certaines
allergies quotidiennes mais également
parce que c'est les valeurs de la
République qui sont battus en brèche et
puis nous voulons aussi marquer
fortement notre solidarité à Christiane
Taubira vous comprenez que
les radicaux c'est aussi
que c'est une diversion cette
mobilisation sur les âmes du racisme il
estime que la France n'est pas plus
raciste aujourd'hui
mais en plus au-delà de ce que je
confirme parce que tout à l'heure il
faut en plus il apprenne à ouvrir les
yeux il y a quand même une montée du
racisme et des actes de violence qui est
un contestable dans ce pays et il
appartient en républicain de dire les
choses clairement seulement peut-être
que Monsieur Copé il est un peu gêné aux
anthonures parce qu'une partie de ces
troupes et de ses élus lors du vers le
Front national mais les grands les
grandes valeurs les grands principes
c'est ce qui reste à la gauche quand
tout semble lui échapper aujourd'hui
notamment la situation économique leur
situation commune ne nous échappe pas
elle est difficile nous faisons tout
pour la surmonter nous ferons tout pour
redresser le pays mais ces valeurs sont
les notes ou même quand elles sont
partagées par la droite dites
républicaine et non seulement à vie et
j'aimerais qu'on davantage la dent de
républicaine en ce moment
il fallait pas ouvrir les vannes faisant
un référence à Manuel Valls
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et dans la maternelle
permanente c'est son point de commerce
et c'est ce qui fait que vous parlez
beaucoup de lui voilà et alors il est
toujours dans des expressions d'ailleurs
il y a beaucoup de talents pour trouver
les formules on peut pas quand même
reconnaître on peut pas reprocher à
Manuel Valls de faire son travail de
ministre de l'intérieur c'est pas lui
qui a ouvert les vans Les Vans sont
ouvertes pendant un discours xénophobe
raciste parfois antisémite qui est tenu
quand même généralement par les troupes
et les responsables du Front national
merci Katel petite question j'aime chez
le Bay était si demain comme on le dit
les verres quittent le gouvernement ce
serait une perte irrémédiable pour ce
dernier ce serait dommage parce que vous
êtes inscrit la majorité très sincère
plus la majorité large plus elle
reprennent la diversité mieux c'est pour
la conduire les affaires du pays je n'ai
pas envie d'aller voir que ma sincérité
je vais au bout je n'ai pas envie de
voir les socialistes seul au
gouvernement parce que à ce moment-là ce
serait l'État socialiste et ça n'est
jamais bon il faut soyons là les Verts
les verts avec leur particularité j'ai
pas toujours d'accord avec eux les
radicaux de gauche et peut-être quelques
ordres pour de temps en temps rappeler
pas peur au sein de la République en
danger mais mais mes peurs parce qu'on
fait pas peur si vous guide pas peur au
sein de la République en danger mais je
trouverai que ce ne serait pas bon pour
la France parce qu'il faut que
l'ensemble des familles politiques et
courantes de pensées politiques de la
gauche soit représenté au gouvernement
quelques autres
et maintenant les difficultés du Sénat
où vous siégé donc avec per internaute
qui va nous rejoindre dans un instant
l'absence d'une majorité de gauche du
moins aligné derrière le gouvernement
rend on le voit trop souvent
impossible le vote de certaines réformes
au-delà des majorités de circonstances
qu'ils forment de plus en plus souvent
l'UMP et les communistes par exemple se
disent aujourd'hui humilier et voient
même le Sénat comme une institution en
sursis en péril c'est le rejet de trop
lors du vote du budget de la Sécurité
sociale la semaine dernière la ministre
de la Santé Marisol Touraine a voulu
passer en force supprimant les
amendements déposés et demandant un vote
bloqué sur le texte initial de quoi
lever contre elle une majorité de
l'hémicycle c'est tout le travail
parlementaire de trois jours d'efforts
que vous mettez à bas vous mettez le
Sénat au garde à vous devant l'Assemblée
nationale c'est le Sénat qui est méprisé
aujourd'hui et je trouve que ce VOC
bloqué effectivement pose la question la
légitimité du Sénat et du rapport du
gouvernement au Sénat une fois de plus
mais une fois de trop au sein de la
majorité même certains parlent d'une
humiliation quant à l'opposition elle
pose la question d'une redéfinition du
rôle du Sénat madame Touraine pour ne
pas la nommer porte une énorme
responsabilité elle était MDA à dire que
de toute façon pouvait faire ce qu'on
voulait au Sénat c'est l'Assemblée
nationale Corée le dernier mot d'un
point de vue constitutionnel c'est tout
à fait exact mais là aussi le
gouvernement prend une énorme
responsabilité je crois qu'il y a un
problème politique majeur auquel
beaucoup de sénateurs bien au-delà de
l'opposition sont particulièrement
sensibles
justement le sénateur centriste Jean
Arthuis a reçu du président du Sénat la
mission de proposer des alternatives à
la situation actuelle le fameux
bicamerisme rénové souhaité par
Jean-Pierre Bell nous sommes dans la
bêtise enfin dans le conservatif nous
continuons à véhiculer des propos des
schémas qui sont périmés et donc
capables de s'affranchir des contraintes
partisanes pour articuler des
propositions crédibles qui redonne le
sport et la confiance d'autres voix
s'élèvent et proposent de copier le
modèle allemand un sénat qui
représenterait les régions et
examinerait les lois mais loin d'être
une priorité de François Hollande une
réforme du Sénat si elle était décidée
par l'exécutif devrait être validé par
les deux assemblées réunies en congrès
un projet bien incertain qui fait
craindre au sénateur que le Palais du
Luxembourg ne devienne qu'un simple site
touristique
voilà donc pour l'état du Sénat
aujourd'hui vu par François Goulin avec
nous Perrine d'Arnaud vos questions sur
ce thème notamment pas seulement
Jean-Michel Baillet
de vos collègues sénateurs qu'on vient
de voir dans ce reportage que le Sénat
est menacé
je ne le crois pas je ne le crois pas
car les institutions de la Cinquième
République sont solides et nous sommes
en bicamérisme et je ne vois pas
supprimer une chambre et devenir
monocorne ce qui serait très mauvais
d'ailleurs et pour la République au nom
des principes et pour le fonctionnement
institutionnel et donc législatives
parce que l'Assemblée nationale très
souvent et plus un forum qu'une
assemblée initiative où on s'affronte
droite gauche sans trop se mêler du
travail législatif alors qu'ici on fait
quand même beaucoup de travail
législatif et on sait prendre le temps
néanmoins aujourd'hui c'est elle qui est
le dernier mot sur les principaux textes
du
gouvernement
et il se trouve qu'au Sénat la gauche et
majoritaire en principe
mais la gauche gouvernementale l'est pas
car pour qu'il y ait les six petits
doigts à l'avance il faut les
communistes on les communistes ne sont
pas dans la majorité la majorité c'est
les socialistes les écologistes et les
radicaux de gauche donc c'est très
difficile quand on a une majorité aussi
mince d'arriver à passer les textes et
ça demande beaucoup de patience et de
tactes ce qui n'est pas toujours le cas
et ça ne fait qu'aggraver les choses
mais un nouveau nombre de voix
le débat il y a quelques jours
sur le but d'une sécu retraites avec la
même ministre
fait tomber tous les amendements qui ont
été adoptés y compris sur propositions
pour revenir au texte initial un peu
brutalement je ne trouve pas comme
maître suffisamment l'effort pour
arriver à faire une majorité surtout
dans une assemblée ou c'est difficile
comme ici mais le vous sentez comme
d'autres sénateurs négligés par le
gouvernement voir mépriser
ni méprises
simplement et beaucoup de textes sont
passés ici quand il faut pas il ne faut
pas l'oublier
très importants mais certains n'ont
peut-être parce que les mini n'ont pas
suffisamment fait le travail de
concertation peut-être aussi parce qu'il
n'y a pas eu assez de volonté du
gouvernement je vous parlais des textes
institutionnels concernant les radicaux
de nous entendre et et de nous écouter
mais je le répète les choses maintenant
vaut mieux c'est pour le gouvernement
c'est pour le gouvernement national au
gouvernement qui finalement ne prennent
pas assez le temps de venir vendre leurs
projets de loi ici au Sénat les
ministres font selon leur propre
tempérament quel que soit les
gouvernements il en est qui
naturellement rond davantage la
concertation et le dialogue spontané que
d'autres et puis il en est aussi qui
connaissent mieux le travail
parlementaire parce qu'ils ont été
parlementaire donc ça ça aide quand même
quand un ministre connaît le Parlement
il s'est un peu comment ça fonctionne
c'est c'est plus facile mais ici c'est
une assemblée difficile et qui ne me
semble pas menacé je trouve qu'elle ne
serait plus si on persiste à vouloir
instituer le Haut Conseil des
territoires des territoires parce que à
partir du moment et ça va rejoindre une
question vous allez me poser où en est
difficile
et venir aussi mais c'est aussi sur la
proposition de Gérard Collomb de faire
du Sénat français une assemblée des
territoires comme le bonheur
française et puis ce sont des permis de
continuer à cumuler ce sont des membres
de droits moi j'aime les élections je
trouve qu'il faut avoir la légitimité du
suffrage universel pour pouvoir
s'exprimer
nous sommes normalement là au Conseil
commune de France et c'est pour ça que
cette loi interdisant un sénateur d'être
mère et et une loi que j'ai combattu et
que je continue à considérer que c'est
une mauvaise une mauvaise loi d'autant
plus qu'elle va pas au fond des choses
du cumul pour tous les parlementaires
donc dans la version initiale de la
force que le scénario ça c'est
l'application à cause du chiot c'est
l'assemblée que le dernier mot en cas de
chèque de CMP ça ne se passe pas souvent
mais revenons au fond un sénat qui
n'aura pas un seul maire même d'une
commune de serviteur quand dans la même
temps on laisse les prix en des grandes
villes le président aussi le est-ce que
ça prend plus de temps d'être sénateur
et merde une commune de 200 habitat
qu'être mère de Lille de Lyon ou de
Toulouse et présente la métropole moi je
pense que le débat il est posé il
n'avait pas changer
les sénateurs ne seront plus des neuron
plus en contact à la réalité du terrain
dans leur commune dans leur département
ou dans leur région et comme par
ailleurs on veut créer un Haut Conseil
des territoires qui seraient consultés
surtout les textes concernant les
collectivités je dis que là oui là
effectivement le Sénat n'est pas bien
questionne tant que tel mais son
autorité à représenté les collectivités
c'est clair et moi je ne suis pas
d'accord donc il ne faut pas créer ce
conseil des territoires et nous sommes
dans ce débat actuellement vous avez été
beaucoup critiqué vous les défenseurs du
cumul des mandat par la presse nationale
vous avez été traité de ringard comment
vous avez vécu cet épisode mais ça moi
j'ai des commissions vous savez faire de
la politique c'est hors des convictions
Chevilly au corps et même contre vos
idées sont minoritaires il faut se
battre pour les rendre majoritaires bon
là il est pas arrivé à les rendre
majoritaires mais je suis sûr que nous
avons et notre conscience et et la
réalité de la raison pour nous car des
élus il faut qu'il soit sur le terrain
il faut qu'il soit près de leur
concitoyens il faut il faut qu'il soit
dans les collectivités surtout
concernant le Sénat ça va être quoi un
silence en local mais ça va être quoi
surtout pour les références tout à
l'heure il faut revenir au bicamery
intégral et que les Sénats l'assemblés
et et et et les mêmes pouvoirs et que
l'assemblée ne puisse pas avoir le
dernier mot car normalement dans les
équipes de constitutionnels ici c'était
la chambre des collectivités mais ne
jamais collectivités sans responsable
collectivité c'est une originalité quand
même que l'on doit pas trouver
facilement on change de sujet
Jean-Michel Bailey Elisabeth Badinter la
philosophe estime que ce n'est pas
l'état de légiférer en matière
d'activité sexuelle elle fait référence
à la proposition de loi qui qui est
passée à l'Assemblée nationale sur la
pénalisation des clients de prostituées
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
Elisabeth bannière dans la presse je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec elle je
pense que ce n'est pas
à la loi de régler ses problèmes là il
faut de la prévention il faut de la
protection il faut lutter contre le
proxénétisme sans faille mais je crois
que il ne faut pas aller plus loin et je
suis tout à fait d'accord à
l'argumentaire et les et les propos de
Elisabeth bonnet considère que ce texte
de loi finalement est synonyme de
prohibition avec d'autres ravages je
pense aux estimations
la prohibition n'a jamais rien réglé au
contraire de la libération de la
consommation de cannabis parce que la
prohibition ne règle rien elle elle au
contraire elle organise tout un tas de
réseau
clandestins souterrain
que qui sont pires que le mal d'ailleurs
il n'est qu'avoir pour le cannabis c'est
de cela que vous voulez que l'on parle
maintenant
vous cherchez des amis
vous savez les premiers écologistes a
été les radicaux Michel Crépeau à La
Rochelle il a quand même donné l'exemple
de l'écologie
qui devrait ne pas avoir oublié
certaines leçons de Michel Crépeau en
particulier en matière quant au fait
qu'il ne faut jamais rien concéder sur
les principes républicains voilà je vous
l'ai dit tout à l'heure que quand on
appelle les lycéens
donc la prohibition sans règle rien la
preuve d'ailleurs c'est que la France
est un des pays où on consomme le plus
cannabis en Europe
une proposition de loi certainement à
quelques avec quelques écologistes mais
on va prendre un peu le temps de le
faire quand même on va pas rajouter des
difficultés difficultés
sur ce principe de dire que il faut
légaliser que ça réglera un point
sécurité publique ce sont les dealers
dans les cages d'escalier et sur les
plages
sécurité sanitaire aussi parce qu'on
leur demande des saloperies une dernière
question sur les aides à la presse pour
terminer cette émission des aides à la
presse en forte baisse dans le projet de
loi de finances 2014 quelques 200
millions d'euros voilà on s'adresse au
patron de presse c'est exactement le
patron de la Dépêche du Midi notamment
des aides en baisse sur les aides au
transport postal est-ce que c'est le
coup de grâce pour votre secteur
d'activité je n'aime pas mélanger les
jambes en fait je vais vous répondre
quand même généralement où je m'occupe
de de ma vie professionnelle de ma vie
politique mais jamais là jamais les deux
ce que je pense c'est que si très vite
on ne fait pas pour la presse un plan
comme Jacques land en Santa si le faire
pour le pour le cinéma la presse écrite
qui est quand même de l'eau bien
culturelle et un de nos biens de liberté
disparaîtra parce qu'elle est écrasée
par un système économique qui n'est plus
pertinent par la concurrence du net qui
a enfoncé la gratuité dans l'esprit des
gens et par le fait que ce soit pour
l'information ou que ce soit pour les
recettes publicitaires tout le monde
part sur le net la télévision d'ailleurs
aussi les mêmes problèmes
est-ce que des fois bien ce secteur
qui va créer un nouveau modèle
économique
je vous répète il faut faire un plan de
sauvetage de la presse comme et de
sauvegarde comme ça a été fait pour le
livre et pour le cinéma très bien merci
beaucoup merci Monsieur ballet merci
Perrine merci bonsoir la semaine
prochaine c'est Jean-Claude Gaudin qui
sera notre invité bonsoir à très vite